Speaker 1: I sadly am going to play for you
today some of the scariest audio and video
that we've had on the show for for a while.
We have seen people show up at school boards
or city council meetings recently and call
for the killing of gay people, of LGBT people.
Today, I'm going to play for you a clip of a
candidate calling for the killing of the parents
of LGBT kids. This is candidate Mark Burns.
It might not shock you that Mark Burns is a
Trumpist. He loves Trump. He's pro-Trump. He is
running in the fourth District in South Carolina.
And he called for the arrest and execution
of those who advocate for LGBT rights
and the protection of trans children. This was
during an appearance on the Stu Peters show,
and he talked about that he is committed to voting
for transphobic laws which will target LGBT kids
and their parents. And then he went further than
saying he will just vote for the legislation.
He says he wants those parents held for child
abuse and put to death if they are convicted. Take
a look at this. This is extraordinarily dangerous.
Speaker 3: The LGBT, transgender grooming,
our children's mind is a national security threat.
Speaker 1: Now, by the way, I hate to already
interrupt the day when Republicans and right
wingers get a new shiny toy. In this case,
it's the word grooming. They use it all the
time. Grooming has a very specific meaning in
the context of child abuse. And, you know, saying
to your kids, I love you no matter who you are.
It's not really grooming. It's
actually not at all grooming. But
they're just using the word there on the word.
Speaker 3: Because it is ultimately designed
to destabilize the republic we call the United
States of America. That's why when I'm elected,
I don't want to just vote. I want to
start holding people accountable for
treason to the Constitution. I am going to push
to reenact Kwak, who is the house of an American
Activities Committee. It was a real committee
that was formulated back in the fifties and is
a committee that we should reenact that starts
holding these people accountable for treason. We
need to hold people for treason. Start having some
public hearings and start executing people who are
found guilty for their treasonous acts against
the Constitution of the United States of America.
Speaker 1: Do you understand how insane
that is? Who ask? So first of all. I mean,
at putting to death the parents of LGBT kids.
It's dangerously off the rails. But there is
another aspect to this. When we talk about who
act the House Committee on un-American Activities.
We're talking about McCarthyism. We're talking
about a committee that looks at whether Americans
have been disloyal, don't have to have committed
any crime. It's just a do you think the wrong
things, which we have tagged as being a lack of
loyalty to the United States, extraordinarily
dangerous candidate. Now, does this guy have a
shot at winning? Well, we'll have to wait and see.
Would it be a shock to me if this guy actually
ended up getting arrested for, you know, domestic
violence, child porn, whatever? I'm not saying I
have any evidence of that, but no, oftentimes the
loudest people who say, let me one up, even you,
it's not enough just to say I'm going to vote. I
will demand the killing. Sometimes when people go
overboard like that, it's because they have things
to hide. We don't know that to be the case with
this guy, but that's something that we've seen.
But we seem to live in a world where people can
freely express their desire for large swaths
of people to be killed. Now I get it. He's
not personally threatening to kill anybody.
This is not the type of thing where you would
say, well, you know, we're from the police and
we need to talk to you. But the reaction is, well,
yeah, I mean, just if you don't like that, don't
vote for him as if this counts as anything even
remotely approximating valid political discourse.
I it's it's a it's it's increasingly dangerous.
Not only that people are saying these things,
but they they aren't instantly disqualifying.
And we go back to 2016, 2015, Trump and the
Access Hollywood tape and the entire thing. At
a certain point in American political history,
the Access Hollywood grab him by the you know,
what tape would have been a disqualifier. That
would have been just, oh, you're done. You
resign immediately and that's it. It's over.
And there is almost nothing that they can't
try to explain away at this point in time. Now,
this guy is pro-Trump. Trump hasn't endorsed him.
So it's not a situation where Trump would pull
his endorsement or anything like that, but
it's considered just like, Oh, yeah, well, no,
I'm against killing the people, the parents of
LGBT kids, so I'm not going to vote for him.
This should be immediately disqualifying,
and it's not in modern American politics.